en face et verticale au dessus il faudra
en faire plus large de leur fantaisie
l'après fera que tu partes vraie phrase
voilà tu veux faire un plan plus large
là lorsque langue étrangère et pour moi
il faut que je prête nom reste l'adresse
de vincent guay on va leur prendre dans
ce live oui de levier vis du tout au
rien du tout public attend on revient on
revient sur le jeu pas pour faire court
on tourne on tourne en rond n'arrête pas
de tourner et on reste large
c'est bien un quelqu'un pense à sauver
sur la croix du milieu à la douche me
revoilà joue bien sur la croix et en
milieu centre de bière
pour partager mon parti me paraît tout
droit
tu veux qu'on fasse croire c'est bien je
viens comme ça y est on se parle on se
barre et on se parle en coûtera plus de
20 ans oui robert de regret c'est bon
c'est bon sauveur hockey à tourner
c'est ce que à tan tan qui oui parce que
j'aimerais c'est qu'on parte de loin de
voir le paysage doit la rivière et
conditions kaka luis tu es l'alsacien
plus petite part de loin et qui a apaisé
les qui descendent déçu que tu vois où
qu'on arrive dans quelque chose que toi
nous ne comptons pas directement sur
quoi tu vois pas ce qu'est la rivière
peut naître paris viii toi je dois la
droite et des ps2 voilà becker écran
qu'à un plan assez loin pas bon je te
pas très beau c'est bon je pense que
yahoo on va être très dense comme ça on
va tourner au futile va descendre tu vas
serré sur la croquer yann est ce qu'on
peut arriver regarde on peut arriver par
le paravent beaucoup beaucoup plus beau
après dans ce qui est important c'est la
croix le paysage est pas très beau sinon
on se concentre dans la croix ok allez
chiche au dessus
on se concentre dessus parce que ces
paysages est pas bon du tout par rapport
à ce qu'on va voir
j'ai des paysages de mer par rapport à
trouver voilà un tournant cela s'est
bien passé bien verticale pour un jeu de
passes verticales verticale savent pas
ou pas c'est bien qu'ils passent devant
ce très joli alemanno qui passent
regardent
voilà on peut se rapprocher pierre
lacroix au milieu des miens c'est bien
on les a on les a bien un paysage etc un
peu de style mari peter v sens dessus
dessous dessus nous a toujours fait
c'est bien un lien entre vachement ou la
plus tard hockey est normalement tu
devrait ressortir tuerait refuserait pas
de thé vers le haut pas les chercher là
tu vas bien sûr l'iran soit bien sûr la
croix qu'on la voit bien qu'on la voit
en plein écran
d'intéressantes edwards en plein écran
la croix décembre ce qui m'intéresse
c'est vraiment ce truc qui m'intéresse
le dessin de lacroix doit des arbres
voilà jean plus sûr et plus heureux
aussi tournés vers le choc après ça ne
m'a pas tant on se barre alors dépassé
de power le plan est bon pas la bible en
jeu jusqu'à jusqu'à qu'on a serré mais
pas la fin quand même la fin il y eut un
temps qu'est ce qu'on fait on pour nous
pas assez peut-être michel faut le
laisser tourner je pense là ont tous un
ollie doucement comme ça c'est pas mal
c'est nous on va partir en avant aux
quêtes en fait on pourra les commenter
le cospar porgy vers la gauche
ouais vers la gauche mais ça à faire ça
va faire un gros temps où les aléas des
patients des partis à la coupe à la
coupe un accusé d'obtenir à partir trop
vite par 3,8 par 3500 nationalement
verticale là on n'arrive pas à le tenir
faute là moi je sais pas enfin c'est bon
ça ils sont
moi je propose qu'on parte de la rivière
que ta garde à 9 heures là bas et qu'on
remonte à gérer je vais avoir pas mal ça
regarde si on parle de la rivière labaki
à 9 heures on compte entre amis qu'avant
tarifs sur les arbres c'est vraiment un
tout petit truc ça c'est un truc c'est
un détail où on va aller directement
plutôt un problème à ce que c'est que
d'avoir pas secondes bon là dessus qu'on
voit les a ou pas oui la seconde au
lycée partie ment